Mark Klein a brilliant DARPA researcher
is embarking on an intriguing journey to
Moldova the current deployment location
of the U.S military during the ongoing
moldovan War driven by curiosity and
Innovation he is summoned to consult on
his groundbreaking creation which is an
impressive line of hyperspectral Imaging
goggles they have already been issued to
the Troops on the front lines upon
landing at a U.S military air base on
the outskirts of chisi now Dr Klein is
greeted by two key individuals the
no-nonsense U.S army General Orland and
the resourceful CIA officer Fran Madison
they waste no time and show him the
remarkable footage captured by the
troops goggles consequently revealing
the presence of an enigmatic translucent
humanoid Apparition that possesses the
ability to eliminate its Targets in a
blink of an eye while General Orlin
seeks Dr Klein's expert opinion before
escalating the findings and footage to
his higher ups CIA officer Fran Madison
holds a contrasting perspective she
believes that these sightings might be
linked to the local Insurgency and
suspects the insurgents are employing an
advanced form of active camouflage
Madison has been specific tasked by her
superiors to retrieve a sample of this
technology for further investigation in
order to capture clearer images of the
mysterious apparitions and determine
their nature Dr Klein and agent Madison
joined forces with a team of Highly
skilled Delta Force operators venturing
into the field to locate the missing
Utah team that vanished the previous day
Dr Klein mounts a larger and more potent
version of the hyperspectral camera on
an armored personnel carrier to improve
their chances of obtaining better Visual
Evidence upon reaching the designated
area a grim Discovery awaits them the
members of the Utah team except for one
Survivor named Comstock are found dead
alongside the insurgents they were
battling suddenly they find themselves
ambushed by the lethal apparitions who
seem invulnerable to Small Arms fire and
explosives causing significant
casualties among the soldiers in the
face of this Relentless assault the
surviving team members are forced to
retreat tragically their dire situation
worsens when their vehicles are rendered
inoperable by landmines this results in
the death of Comstock in order to seek
Refuge the group rests within an
abandoned Factory where they stumble
upon two terrified children barricaded
inside astonishingly the apparitions are
unable to breach the barrier of iron
shavings that surrounds the building
protecting the survivors the children
explain that their father scattered the
shavings to safeguard them before he
himself was killed contacting the nearby
Air Base the survivors established a
rendezvous Point Dr Klein ingeniously
modifies the hyperspectral camera into a
powerful Searchlight enabling the group
to see the apparitions without relying
on goggles inside the factory numerous
crates filled with iron shavings provide
a valuable resource the team converts
their grenades into improvised explosive
devices IEDs infused with iron shavings
bolstering their chances against their
formidable adversaries empowered by
these new weapons the resilient group
embarks on a dangerous journey toward
the Rendezvous Point located roughly
half a mile away from the factory with
extraction time rapidly approaching the
apparitions managed to breach the
barrier forcing the survivors to abandon
their Sanctuary time becomes a crucial
Factor as they push onward their minds
filled with the mixture of determination
and fear the Relentless Pursuit
continues as the group is chased by the
apparitions employing the iron
explosives to impede their advance in a
critical turn of events reinforcements
and a helicopter evacuation team arrive
at the Rendezvous point a mostly
deserted Plaza however their respite is
short-lived as they fall into another
well-planned Ambush by the apparitions
in a desperate struggle for survival
they managed to narrowly escape but not
without losing one of the children and
the soldiers sent to Aid them as the
circumstances get more intense the
survivors receive urgent communication
from General Orland they are given the
startling news that the apparitions have
overrun the air base necessitating a
change of plans they are redirected to a
civilian bunker under the control of the
allied moldovan military for their
safety reflecting on the information
provided by the young girl they rescued
Dr Klein's analytical mind begins to
piece together a crucial theory he
deduces that the apparitions are likely
human-made and constructed from Bose
Einstein condensate a state of matter
that explains their ability to pass
through walls induce freezing
temperatures and their vulnerability to
iron shavings and ceramic materials this
Insight sheds light on their previous
encounters such as the apparitions being
unable to penetrate ceramic tank armor
or discovering Comstock hiding beneath
the bathtub working tirelessly through
the night Dr Klein collaborates with
General Orland and the remaining
military engineers to construct
makeshift pulse weapons capable of
disrupting the Bose Einstein condensate
their determination knows no bounds as
they prepare for the impending
confrontation with the break of dawn the
surviving American soldiers armed with
the newly developed pulse weapons board
V-22 Ospreys and set out on a critical
Mission Dr Klein's deduction leads them
to the Heart of the City which is the
masarov power plant believing it to be
the sole facility capable of generating
the necessary power for creating the
condensate they set their sights on this
pivotal location as the soldiers execute
an attack on the rooftop of the power
plant in order to create a diversion Dr
Klein and agent Madison Venture into a
recently overtaken laboratory deep
within its confines a startling
Revelation awaits them as they piece
together the truth behind the
apparitions they uncover that the
laboratory was once a clandestine
facility where scientists working under
the previous regime's weapons research
program had developed a Sinister method
these scientists were conducting
molecular level scans of human subjects
and using Advanced 3D printing
technology to replicate them in the form
of Bose-Einstein condensate the process
involved extracting the subject's brains
and peripheral nervous systems which
were then linked to a central machine
responsible for sustaining the
condensate copies the very apparitions
they had been facing with the ongoing
Battle Above threatening to release the
remaining condensate copies Dr Klein
races against time to activate the
Fail-Safe system he had been tirelessly
working on as the system activates a
wave of deactivation sweeps through the
laboratory rendering the condensate
apparitions dormant yet Dr Klein
realizes that even in their deactivated
State there may be residual
Consciousness lingering within the
captured human remains filled with
empathy and compassion he makes a
poignant decision unplugging the
preserved brains and nervous systems
from the machine he grants the subjects
the long-awaited release from their
ethereal existence offering them a final
respite from their suffering in this
profound moment of humanity the
survivors bring closure not only to
their own perilous ordeal but also to
the tormented Souls trapped within the
condensate copies as peace settles over
the power plant they emerge from the
depths forever changed by their
experiences with the threat of the
apparitions finally eliminated the
combined forces of the U.S and allied
moldovan military pressed forward in
their mission to regain control of the
city from the Insurgent forces a
well-coordinated effort is underway to
restore peace and stability to the
region recognizing the significance of
the recently conquered power plant the
Department of Defense prepares to
dispatch an extraction team composed of
skilled Delta Force operators their
objective is to carefully dismantle the
Machinery responsible for creating the
condensate apparitions with the
potential of repurposing it for their
own strategic Endeavors as the time for
departure draws near Dr Klein bids
farewell to agent Madison and general
Orland expressing his gratitude for
their unwavering support and camaraderie
throughout their shared ordeal their
paths diverge at this juncture as Klein
prepares to embark on a V-22 Osprey that
will transport him back home to Virginia
filled with a mixture of relief and
reflection Dr Klein boards the aircraft
carrying with him the knowledge and
experiences acquired during his time in
Moldova the journey back to Virginia
symbolizes a return to a semblance of
normalcy where he can further analyze
and understand the implications of the
extraordinary events he witnessed as the
V-22 Osprey takes to the skies Dr Klein
contemplates the profound impact of his
work and the Newfound understanding he
has gained the memories of the
apparitions and the harrowing Journey he
shared with Madison and the military
forces will forever shape his
perspective and drive future research
Endeavors as we conclude this gripping
tale we are left with an intriguing
question what are the long-term
consequences of the technology uncovered
in the power plant will it be harnessed
for good or fall into the wrong hands
potentially unleashing a new era of
warfare let us know in the comments down
below click on one of the two videos on
screen right now
foreign